we celebrate the 150th anniversary of
the magazine selected readings by James
Fallows Christopher Hitchens William
Longo Isha and others this is just over
an hour this program contains language
that some may find offensive good
evening everyone I'm Karla Cohen I'm one
of the owners of politics and prose and
I want to welcome everybody here tonight
thanks for coming out
in spite of the rain which we of course
need very badly so we're we can make
this kind of a rain dance
congratulations to the Atlantic Monthly
Magazine we're so pleased that you've
chosen to celebrate your 150th
anniversary with us thanks to David
Bradley the owner who has been such a
good friend of writing and books my job
is very simple tonight I introduce
Robert Baer the editor of large of
Atlantic and he will introduce the
writers who have joined us some among
the scores of writers represented in
this generous compendium the American
idea Robert there is a experienced
writer and editor having worked at The
New Yorker and Rolling Stone before his
stint of the Atlantic Monthly it is he
who chose and organized the pieces that
are included here he said in his
introduction he did not expect to find
in the magazine's archive such a quote
splendid view of the many events and
currents of American history he has
given each of the pieces an introduction
and provides a context for the reader
he has also set the anthology free of
what he calls free of a chronological
organization grouping the materials in a
series of categories which I'm sure he
will want to talk about
I love the minute I love this book from
the minute that I saw an advance copy
and of course the finished book is much
better if I were teaching a course in
American history I would need no other
text than this book congratulations to
you Robert and to all of your
contributors
good evening everyone it's nice to see
you all and so many nice to see so many
familiar faces and it's it's great to be
back at politics and prose which is got
to be one of the outstanding bookstores
in America if not the world
we're here tonight to celebrate not just
the publication of a new book but also
the hundred and fiftieth anniversary of
a genuine American publishing
institution the Atlantic Monthly cannot
lay claim to being the oldest magazine
in America
I'm afraid that distinction belongs to
Scientific American which was founded in
1845 and Town and Country and Harper's
magazines were both founded a few years
before the Atlantic and yet at the ripe
old age of 150 the Atlantic does have
the right to call itself America's
oldest continuously published general
interest magazine by any standard
assessed with centennial as a remarkable
achievement especially in a notoriously
fragile sector of the publishing
universe where the average life
expectancy of a magazine of a new
magazine is something closer to a
hundred and fifty days not a hundred and
fifty years so how do we account for the
Atlantic's astonishing longevity you
know I wish I had a simple soundbite
answer to that question but when you
look at the history of the magazine I
think a couple of important explanations
do seem to come to the fore and begin to
explain this remarkable longevity the
first has to do with the Atlantic's
unusual genealogical tree as some of you
may know the Atlantic was founded by a
remarkable group an illustrious group
representing some of the towering figure
of mid of 19th century American
intellectual life there was Ralph Waldo
Emerson in Oliver Wendell Holmes and
Henry Wadsworth Longfellow and James
Russell Lowell at the time of the
magazine's founding in 1857 these were
the golden boys of American literature
philosophy and science and they set a
pretty high standard for their
successors to live up to and I would
like to add that unlike many other
magazines that oh there start - usually
- business people investors people on
the publishing side the Atlantic was
started by a group largely consisting of
writers and I think that as if you and I
think that because of that at its core
it has always been a writer's magazine
and if you think of it as a writer's
magazine you you begin to understand how
the Atlantic has managed to attract so
many of the most esteemed and revered
writers and thinkers of the last century
and a half the list of names is like a
who's who in American literature from
novelists like Nathaniel Hawthorne Edith
Wharton William Faulkner Saul Bellow
Philip Roth to scientists Albert
Einstein Jay Robert up
J robert Oppenheimer James Watson
Stephen Jay Gould Leo Wilson from
economists like John Maynard Keynes and
John Kenneth Galbraith and Milton
Friedman - humorous like Mark Twain
HL Mencken Garrison Keillor and Ian
Frazer from muckrakers like Jacob Riis
Lincoln Steffens and Henry Demarest
Lloyd the granddaddy of all muckrakers -
philosophers like William James Bertrand
Russell Alfred North Whitehead
from poets like Yates Wallace Stevens
Robert Lowell Sylvia Plath WH Auden two
future presidents three future
presidents wrote for the Atlantic before
the White House was even a gleam in
their in their eye they were Theodore
Roosevelt Woodrow Wilson and John
Fitzgerald Kennedy so I like to think of
the if you think of the the Atlantic as
a writer's magazine started by writers
with this remarkable genealogical tree
that I think would be one factor in its
longevity and a second factor I would
point to is a few words that are
embedded in a brief mission statement
that the founders whom I mentioned
published in the magazine's first issue
and this these words are almost buried
within the few quiet sentences of that
mission statement which sketched out
editorial goals and policies and it was
an assertion that the magazine would be
primarily dedicated to monitoring
exploring and promoting something the
founders called the American idea
exactly what they meant by that term
they never made clear either in their
mission statement or in their public
statements or private journals but we
can make some educated guesses about
what they were talking about certainly
they were talking about political
democracy they were talking about
personal freedom they were talking about
social justice and they were probably
talking about economic opportunity all
of those goals after all were enumerated
and spelled out in the declaration of
independence and yet it is intriguing
and even a little mist of and also a
little myth mystifying to me at least
that the founders would give such way to
a term this term the American idea that
does not appear to have been in common
use at the time in retrospect it's
almost as though they had a certain
confidence that their readers
know exactly what they had in mind in
any event by of invoking this simple
three word phrase the American idea
the founders managed to infuse their
magazine with both an identity and a
calling and I at bottom I think they
were making an implicit promise to their
readers that the Atlantic would be
taking on the large and perennial
irrelevant questions of our national
life what does it mean to be an American
what constitutes the national interest
what should America's role in the world
be these questions are very much at the
heart of who we are as a magazine a
major part of our genetic heritage and I
think it connects our work with the work
of the founders and with that of all the
other contributors to the magazine over
the course of its history and in very
different ways these questions inform
the work of each of the writers whose
articles in the anthology we honor here
tonight and with that I would like to
introduce our first participant in the
panel tonight we're going to have to
scramble the order because certain
people have been caught in traffic but
I'd like to turn now to the work of Saul
Bellow who was honored in the anthology
with an excerpt from his great novel mr.
Sam lers planet the recipient of three
National Book Awards a Pulitzer Prize
and a Nobel Prize for Literature Saul
Bellow was one of the most honored
writers of the 20th century and yet
throughout his illustrious career as a
writer and as a professor at the
University of Chicago where I was lucky
enough to take a course with him in the
twentieth century novel Bello found
himself was surprising frequency at the
center of political firestorms often as
he himself was first to acknowledge of
his own making a Trotskyist as a young
man Bello veered
sharply to the right in response to the
upheavals of this 1960s and became
well-known in both his novels and public
statements for his pointed and sometimes
inflammatory criticisms of the changes
that were reshaping American culture
higher education and race relations
asked in a 1988 interview for his
opinions of multiculturalism and
non-western literature that were then
ascend and on college campuses Bello
posed a famous question who was the tall
stay of the Zulus the Proust of the
Papuans I'd be glad to meet him that
remark for all its cleverness sounded to
some like a racial put-down but perhaps
the biggest controversy that the Chicago
bred novel has ever set off originated
in the pages of the Atlantic in late in
late 1969 The Magazine serialized to
very large installments of bellows then
forthcoming novel mr. Sandler's planet
at issue was bellows depiction of a
black pickpocket a physically imposing
magnificently dressed african-american
male in his 30s who was spotted by the
novel's title character Arthur Sadler
what I'm gonna
there'll be plenty of times okay Chris
Christopher I knew you'd be keeping me -
taking me to task but but just to move
ahead this depiction of the pet of the
black pickpocket got Bello in all kinds
of trouble and accusations of racial
stereotyping and outright racism rained
down on Bello after that and in fact one
critic who actually was an admirer of
bellos work a man by the name of Joseph
Epstein maintained that mr. Sandler's
planet seemed designed to quote offend
whole categories of the reading public
as well as most of the people who write
about books but other critics and
readers rose to bellas defense
contending that the novelist had himself
been victimized by an early upwelling of
political correctness and that he had
properly exercised the prerogatives of
fiction to present the menacing
character of urban life in New York City
as experienced by at least some of those
who live there to celebrate the excerpt
in the anthology and to honor the work
of Saul Bellow we're delighted to have
with us here tonight an Atlantic
contributing editor a best-selling
author and a provocative essayist and
cultural critic and literary critic
Christopher Hitchens and a bit and I
should say a Bello Bello file
second-to-none who has an excellent
piece in the current one hundred and
fiftieth anniversary issue on Saul
Bellow and I'm sorry Christopher
I just thought your introduction was in
danger of becoming too generous if not
in fact pre-emptive and I've only got a
few minutes with you ladies and
gentlemen and I want to make the best
use of them I wouldn't first give you a
sense of how Bella writes setting a
scene of a an old Jew Holocaust survivor
immigrant to United States who has to
ride the bus and doesn't like what he
sees shortly after dawn or what would
have been dawn in a normal sky mr.
Arturo sampler with his bushy I took in
the books and papers of his West Side
bedroom and suspected strongly that they
were the wrong books the wrong papers in
a way it did not matter much to him out
of 70 plus and at leisure he thought
since he had no job to wake up to that
he might give sleep a second chance to
resolve certain difficulties
imaginatively for him and pulled up the
disconnected electric blanket with this
internal sinews and lumps it was time to
be conscious very great the way that I
can summon enemy and alienation and
enemies of that I think soon comes back
to him why he's working somewhat
distressed for several days mr. Samuel
er returning on the customary bus have
been watching a pickpocket at work the
man got on at Columbus Circle the job
the crime was done by 72nd Street mr.
Samuel er if he'd not been at all
straphanger would not with his one good
eye have seen these things happening but
now he wondered whether he had not drawn
too close whether he had also been seen
seeing the pickpocket himself wore dark
shades he was a powerful new drove in a
camels hair coat dressed with
extraordinary elegance as if by mr. fish
of London or Turnbull & Asser of German
Street mr. Samuel Inoue his England the
Negroes perfect circles of gentian
violet banded with lovely girl turned
towards Amla but the face showed the
effrontery of a big animal Sandler was
not timid you see how Berezovsky of
trouble here the meeting honoured lining
for me but I'm going to underline it
anyway
[ __ ] was not timid but he had had as
much trouble in life as he wanted
good deal of this would never be
accommodated he suspected the criminal
was aware that a tall old white man
passing as blind had seen the - details
of his crimes staring down as if
watching open-heart surgery and though
he'd assembled decided not to turn aside
where the thief looked at him his
elderly his compact civilized face
colored strongly the short hairs
bristled the lips and gums were stinging
he felt a constriction but clutch of
sickness at the base of the skull where
the nerves muscles and blood vessels
were tightly interlaced the breath of
wartime Poland passing over the damaged
tissues that nerve spaghetti as he
thought of it finely wrought I hope you
agree now to the crisis point when
though he realizes and the pickpocket
realizes that they both understand each
other and he follows mr. Samuel er home
everybody's nightmare in New York that
year that a large person of color let's
be honest will follow you back and knows
where you live and will come into your
apartment and well the doorman can't be
bothered and he's looking after the
elevator will say something and mr.
Sandler will say what's the matter what
do you want he was never to hear the
black man's voice he no more spoke than
a puma would puber what he did was to
force Samer into a corner beside the
long blackish carved table a sort of
Renaissance piece by the buckling canvas
of the old wall there the man held sama
against the wall with his forum the
umbrella fell to the floor with a sharp
crack of the ferrule on the tile it was
ignored the pickpocket unbuttoned
himself sampler heard the zipper descend
then the smoke glasses were removed from
Sandler's face and dropped on the table
he was directed suddenly she looked
downward and I should rephrase that he
was directed silently she looked
downward the black manager opened his
fly and taken out his penis it was
displayed to sampler with the great oval
testicles a large tan and purple
uncircumcised thing a tube a snake
metallic hairs bristle did the thick
base and the tip
curled beyond the supporting
demonstrating hand suggesting the fleshy
mobility of an elephant's trunk there
the skin was somewhat iridescent rather
than thick or rough over the forearm and
fists that held him sampler was required
to gaze at this organ no compulsion
would have been necessary he would in
any case have looked okay you may think
that's enough of that
but Bello clearly wants you to be able
to see it and if you like feel it and
he's taking the most daring allegory of
what we used to call race relations that
it's really possible to imagine not just
street crime this time conducted by man
beautifully dressed and very elegant
very skillful but the alleged sexual and
it has to be said animal threat posed by
just in the minds of some white people
by African Americans Africans in fact
mr. Barrow I haven't got time to direct
very much on this but I'd like to say a
few words partly in his defense and
partly in his criticism on this mr.
Miller towards the end of his days
regretted what he'd said about the
Tolstoy of the Zulus and the proust of
the plat ones and actually said that one
of the books that have most influenced
him was a book about chalk at the great
Zulu King a study of Chaka and the Zulu
Kingdom and I don't think he was doing
this just to make nice because I know
for other reasons that when he wrote
Henderson the rain came one of his
earliest novels I hope some of you at
least have read that the only one by the
way with a non-jewish protagonist a sort
of hemingway-esque adventure into Africa
that he read about 200 books about
Africa in order to familiarize himself
enough to do this and and took it very
seriously I was very stirred by what he
found I think that what we're facing
here with mr. sanli and this antagonist
is is a very distraught allegory that
became apparent to a number of people
who become apparent that's what I say in
my essay in the contract magic began to
occur as an allegory at number people in
about 1969 which was that there was a
connection somehow maybe subliminal
between the battle between Israel and
the Arabs in the Middle East and between
Jewish and black Americans in
particularly Brooklyn New York and
Chicago if you remember there was a
phase
strike in ocean hills that year I went
off about two years Jewish teachers
against community control of schools
terrific accusations of an anti-semitic
kind made against Albert Shanker many of
the slogans and banners replicating what
was being said at the time in the
occupied territories of the West Bank in
Gaza
I think this made to bellow the mockery
of what had been the old progressive
idea of an alliance between black and
Jewish people of a progressive kind and
you can find this in his book on
Jerusalem and his non-fiction work to
Jerusalem and back where you rather
describes Jerusalem as an as an
embattled sea of civilization in the
midst of a an ocean of backwardness and
barbarism and you can you can pick up
the echoes of it in many of his other
works as well and the best I can say in
closing is that he registers it honestly
doesn't make any pretense of not feeling
or not fearing what he knew many people
were feeling and were theory doesn't
appeal in my judgment to anything foul
or bigoted or primitive in his reading
feels above all the obligation to state
honestly what is really on people's
minds and I I hope that it will always
be felt by the adventurer but it's our
job to face questions of this kind
however distraught they may seem so
thank you for listening and thank you
for coming thanks
thank you very much Christopher we're
gonna move from Saul Bellow to Sodom
Hussein now four months after the next
article on our program tonight
was assigned it was affectionately known
around the offices of the Atlantic as
the sex life of Saddam Hussein but that
title I think bolide the project serious
objective which was to provide readers
not with just with a detailed pictures
of Saddam's daily life from the moment
he woke up in the morning till the
moment he went to bed at night but
really with a plumb line into the depths
of his psyche and as a high profile
player on the world stage for many years
Saddam Hussein had inspired innumerable
articles and books
the emphasis almost always on his tribal
past his opulent lifestyle and his
murderous regime but rarely had the
Iraqi dictator been written about with
with this level of on this level of
intimacy for this ambitious assignment
the magazine's editors turned to Mark
Bowden the author of an international
bestseller Black Hawk Down and a
reformer reporter for the Philadelphia
Inquirer
with an unusual gift for the
narrative-driven profile unable to gain
an audience with Saddam himself Mark's
request which was sent through the Iraqi
consulate in New York was basically
ignored mark nevertheless was managed to
track down an interview many Iraqi
exiles both foes and allies of Saddam
alike anyone and he traveled to cities
as far-flung as Detroit and Rome for his
reporting and I think it's this
intensive reporting that really informs
this story which is called tales of the
tyrant an article that in its
accretion of purse of personal often
mundane details is it once demonizing
and surprisingly humanizing in in mark
Bowden's impressionistic portrait Saddam
is not as he is often depicted a cartoon
monster but really a deformed man
hopelessly corrupted by his own vain
glory and pathetically constrained by
his own power
I'm delighted too that we have Atlantic
national correspondent Mark Bowden with
us here tonight well thank you very much
it's really nice to see this many people
turnout
I am often asked particularly by young
journalists how they could get my job
which is writing these wonderful pieces
for the Atlantic and I tell them that it
really is simple that just have to write
a best-selling book and and then
everybody kind of beats up a path to
your door
actually I began writing for the
Atlantic
soon after I guess the success of Black
Hawk Down actually Robert you're the one
who called me in and solicited something
from me and I met with Michael Kelly who
was just a delightful pugnacious
character who assigned me this story in
the summer of 2001 and Michael for those
of you who are familiar with him wrote a
book about the first Persian Gulf War
called martyrs day which is a fantastic
piece of reporting and writing and had
remained passionately interested in that
part of the world so much so that he got
himself embedded with the military unit
when the United States invaded Iraq and
and was killed the first American
journalist killed in Iraq but this idea
of trying to
right a profile of Saddam Hussein who
was both one of the most famous people
in the world and one of the least known
people in the world at the same time was
his and I had just begun working on it
when there were the attacks on 9/11 and
I remember Michael called me on that day
and he said mark I want you to just drop
that story about Saddam Hussein I want
you to start thinking about something
having to do with what's happening today
and I don't know what that story is
going to be but at some point you know
over the next few weeks and months we'll
figure out what its gonna be and I want
you to you know think big and we're
gonna you know try and do something
really important and so I thought about
this for several weeks after 9/11 and I
kept coming back to just the preliminary
work I had done on this story about
Saddam Hussein and how much I liked this
idea so I got Michael on the phone
finally and I said Michael I want to
stay with this Saddam Hussein story you
know I I know that the rest of the world
is going to be focused on the attacks of
9/11 and I'm sure that you know many
people will be writing about this and
there will be plenty of books but I've
always been taught by my mentor at the
Philadelphia Inquirer jean-robert's to
Zig when everyone else zags and I said I
kind of like this as a Zig you know and
the reason and he and Michael was
completely supportive of this and said
you know go ahead you know continue to
pursue the story about Saddam I of
course was not going to get to meet
Saddam I did try
I sent my request for an interview to
the Iraqi consulate in New York and they
turned me down and I tried again and
they turned me down again but it was an
opportunity for me to actually test a
principle that I have taught to young
journalists and and that is that the
that one of the less important aspects
of any profile is the interview with the
person that you're
writing about and it's far more
important to observe and to report and
so that meant finding people who knew
Saddam personally and there weren't that
many it was hard to find people who had
had personal interactions with Saddam
Hussein but there was a fairly
significant body of expatriates of
people who had fled Iraq or who had fled
Saddam some of whom had who had worked
very closely with him for a number of
years and I was able to find an
interview a wide variety of people who
at different stages of Saddam's life had
had known him I ended up with a lot of
impressions from people fascinating
things insights into Saddam the person
but without a really coherent idea of
how to structure an article about him
now one of the things that I I also
think most people don't realize about
journalism or the kind of writing I do
anyway it's how much you borrow from
other people whose work you admire and
one of the journalists who I have long
greatly admired is the polish writer
ryszard kept Osinski who died just I
guess earlier this year and I had read a
book by Kevin sinski called the Shah of
Shahs which was a profile it was a
profile and it was kind of a an analysis
of the Iranian Revolution but it was a
profile of the Shah of Iran and I'm sure
that capo sinski had been in the same
roughly the same position that I was in
and that he had a lot of information
about the Shah but he was never going to
form a personal impression of the guy
because he was never going to get within
a quarter mile of him and in that book
the way he wrote it was very
impressionistic each chapter basically
begins with an artifact
I think the first chapter is a
photograph a snapshot of the Shah as a
young man with his family which prompts
cap ocinski to go off on a very
penetrating
essay short essay you know ideas about
the SHA that were spurred by this
artifact this photograph well I didn't
have artifacts of Saddam Hussein but I
loved that way of structuring the story
and it seemed to me to be a perfect
solution to the kind of story where you
have a lot of sort of disparate
information and no real central
narrative threads so the piece that I
ended up writing for the Atlantic was
structured around concepts and passages
from Saddam's speeches his rants which
he gave frequently and and the idea
ultimately was to put yourself in the
skin of the dictator clearly Saddam
Hussein as evil as the rest of the world
thought him to be and believe me he had
plenty of claim to the throne looked at
himself in the mirror every day and no
doubt did not say to himself
aha here is the most evil man in the
world I'm sure that he had his own way
of thinking about himself and so that
was really my goal in this story I'll
read you just the first short paragraph
of the piece to give you an idea of the
kind of intimacy that we were looking
for in this story the tyrant must steal
sleep he must vary the locations and
times he never sleeps in his palaces he
moves from secret bed to secret bed
sleep and a fixed routine are among the
few luxuries denied him it is too
dangerous to be predictable and whenever
he shuts his eyes the nation drip drifts
his iron grip slackens plots congeal in
the shadows for those hours he must
trust someone and nothing is more
dangerous to the tyrant than trust the
idea was to get personal with Saddam and
I think it was a it was an interesting
challenge for me it's the kind of thing
that this magazine allows right
to do I love writing for the Atlantic
because of that opportunity because they
give me a lot of space to write long
I've always battled with newspaper
editors to write longer and longer
stories and I also love the fact that
the Atlantic is not a partisan vehicle
that it doesn't represent any
identifiable ideological stripe that
it's interested in giving journalists
and writers an independent opportunity
to express themselves and and and to
arrive at what they really think about
something my own goal in any story I
write for the Atlantic is to work on it
until I arrive at an independent
understanding of whatever it is I'm
writing about so whether you ultimately
agree with me or not you know if you
read a piece by me or I think by William
or Christopher or anyone who writes for
the Atlantic that you are getting the
writers honest straightforward ideas and
opinions not preformed or or designed to
fit a kind of a an ideological pattern
and no one could be more proud than I am
to be just here with the folks that are
that I'm here with or to be in this
collection it's really one of the
highlights of my career thank you
if if anybody would like to take a seat
we have a lot of seats over here on my
right and so you won't have to say
excuse me please and climb over people
if you don't want to thanks very much
mark
I'm not sure that everyone in the room
will agree with the following assertion
but but I think the run-up to the Iraq
war was was not exactly the American
media's finest hour and we could debate
this later in the months before the
conflict much of the reporting emanating
from the major news organizations seemed
to sound to sound a steady drumbeat
sounded an Amen chorus for the Bush
administration's unannounced but readily
apparent invasion plans one of the few
journalists who did not buy into the
conventional wisdom about the blessings
that regime change would bring to Iraq
was the Atlantic's longtime national
correspondent james Fallows in a
remarkably prophetic cover story called
the 51st state which was published in
November of 2002 a full six months
before the invasion of Iraq Jim fallows
leapfrogged over the question that
seemed to preoccupy most other
journalists at the time how quickly
would Saddam be deposed and raised the
larger questions that that very few as
and certainly not the chief architects
of the war seemed to be asking what
would happen next drawing on dozens of
interviews with military strategists and
myth middle-east
experts Jim fallows was able to
construct elaborate scenarios that
prefigured with extraordinary accuracy
nearly the entire catalog of problems
and dangers and pitfalls that the
american-led occupation has had to face
since the overthrow of Saddam just for
example the breakdown of security and
civil order the absence of political
power needed to control potential
insurgencies the decimation of
infrastructure needed for water and
electricity the looming threat of civil
civil war due to rising sectarian
violence and the probability of a
protracted occupation in the absence of
clear goals for withdrawal as a
follow-up to the 51st state which won a
national magazine award in 2003 Jim
fallows went on to produce a series of
related articles for the Atlantic that
taken as a whole represent one of the
most comprehensive indictments of the
Bush administration's conduct of the war
these articles have been collected in a
book called blind into Baghdad and they
have brought Jim's unusual gifts for
interviewing and document sifting and
synthesizing to a very large national
audience as David Shaw the the Los
Angeles Times media critic said in a
column several years ago if Jim fallows
is not the best journalist of his
generation he is certainly in the top
half dozen it's I feel doubly blessed
because Jim was on the panel with us in
Boston and now here he is in Washington
DC and it's an honor to have Jim fallows
joining us here tonight
thank you very much Robert for your
gracious introduction thank you all for
coming out there many friends the
Atlantic family here many friends of my
own family I'm glad to see you and proud
to do so in this context I want to say
briefly a word about this book that
Robert and Dan Smith put together a word
about the magazine and something that
represents and then a word about the way
I approached this story and what that
shows about the role the atlanticus has
tried to have and I'll read it very
briefly from from the end of the story
as Mark was reading from the beginning
of his Carla mentioned earlier that she
thought this one book would be an
adequate history text I would go farther
than that when I was in college my
concentration was American history and
literature I think this one book would
obviate much of a read it's an
astonishing achievement as Mark was
saying a moment ago it makes mere
mortals like the current employees of
the magazine feel honored and ennobled
and embarrassed in a way to be included
in the ranks of the people here so I
think that if you read this book you
will not be sorry it's a remarkable
tradition that it includes and that
Robert and Dan did a very amazing job of
having headnotes
introductions you know excerpts of the
whole thing so I recommend this is a
book event but even beyond that this is
a superb book say something about the
Atlantic which is observing it's 150
years I am both proud and a little bit
awkward to know that for nearly
one-fifth of that time I've been on the
staff of the magazine I have the same
mixed feelings and knowing that I can
remember and see in my mind my father
going to the mailbox in Redlands
California and taking out the 100th
anniversary issue of the Atlantic
Monthly which had come to our house and
making the squirming elementary school
kids which were me and my siblings
listen as you read an essay by James
Thurber which was part of that because
my dad was trying to polish his humorous
skills and he thought this would be a
way to do it I remember in college how
excited I was to go to the newsstand and
see the latest issues with rape with
Saul Bellow's novel with reportage from
Vietnam and all the rest it is a a
wonderful magazine I think is still the
case that my proudest moment in
journalism when when I was living in
Texas and had my first article published
in the Atlantic Monthly a profile of
Lloyd Bentsen
aspirant to the presidency and thought
you know I still have on my wall that
first issue the first time has my name
in it I've had the privilege of working
for five editors there and there's a
point I will make about them Bob Manning
the man who hired me bill Whitworth who
was there for 20 years
Mike Kelly about whom Mark spoke Cullen
Murphy who was there also for 20 years
and now James Bennett they all have been
superb I've been you know honored to
work for all of them Cullen at the event
in Boston made a point which I think
applies to almost no other publication I
can think of Cohen also knew all these
people and he said he considered all of
them his personal friends so to have 30
years of five editors changing where the
turmoil with magazines still feel this
bond says something about the continuity
of the magazine that is that is
represented here I've worked for three
owners of the magazine we are honored to
have by far the best at the helm now and
in our presence here I think he's over
in the corner David Bradley so that's
that's my my advertisement for the
magazine and for this book let me say
something about the article that I did
that Robert was explaining and what it
shows about an aspect of the Atlantic
that I think is not appreciated by
people who don't have to actually put
the thing out we are a monthly magazine
that might be evident to you from our
name what is not not so evident is that
if you have a monthly magazine you have
to think amazingly far ahead of time of
what you're going to do it takes usually
if you're taken into account the time
for reporting a story and writing it and
doing the fact-checking and doing all
the things that are required to have a
good-looking magazine come out usually
it's six to eight months between the
time you think of an idea and when it
actually comes to a reader's mailbox or
sits in the new standards on the web for
the month and it requires a particular
kind of vision which are our editors
have have had in uncommon an unfortunate
abundance to be able to say we think
there's something that six or eight
months from now will be interesting to
people will change their minds and yet
won't in the meantime either be entirely
made meaningless by events or will be
done to death by the New York Times or
whoever else have you have more horses
to deploy on the subject than we do and
this is a skill that we that the editors
have had
I mentioned that because it was the
genesis of the story for me I'd been
living in County on the west coast in
Seattle in Berkeley for three years
before returning to DC in 2001 my wife
and I moved to Washington on September
9th 2001 on the morning of September
11th of course 2001 the first person I
heard from like Mark was Mike Kelly and
he the cellphone suddenly worked and
Mike said you know go downtown look and
see what's going on he was in Boston
then we have to change all of our plans
and figure out what to do and he made
the point that even though we can't be
timely even though it's going to be six
months before we publish our next story
he wondered the magazine to distinguish
itself in this huge moment in national
history and I think through Williams
work which we'll hear more about a
common ground' Mark's work the tyrant
Christopher's essay I think most of
other reportage we did distinguish
ourselves in breaking news that we were
able to cover with this very long lead
time the effect this had on me is that I
was while others were going off to their
various missions I was supposed to work
on the DC policy front and early in 2002
I think was in March in 2002 when Mike
was my delegate on other projects :
Murphy came to me and said we know this
war is going to come or were 95% sure we
know we're going to win and we also know
that probably for quite a while nobody
is going to get around to reporting what
happens after we win so let's get on
that story so starting in March of 2002
for about the next three or four months
I interviewed everybody I could find who
knew about occupations who knew about
victories people who knew about how Iraq
worked people who knew what the was
extrapolated or not from the occupations
of you know you name it Haiti the
Philippines and so I had a long sort of
set of interviews with these people I
wrote a sort of timeline of what you
expect after a week and after a month
and after a year some of the things that
I wrote I would write differently if I
could do it five five years five years
later but most of these most of the
findings that people told me were
depressingly prescient and then the way
they what they have said
let me read now just from the end which
is out of out of sync and away from the
rest of the article because I try to
take a more positive approach there this
is a way this article ended
so far we've considered the downside
which to be fair is most of what I
my interviews but there was also a
distinctly positive theme and it came
from some of the most dedicated members
of the war party their claim again was
that forcing regime change would have
not just a negative virtue that of
removing a threat it would also create
the possibility of bringing to Iraq and
eventually the whole Arab world
something that is never known before
stable democracy in an open market
system quote this could be the golden
opportunity to begin to change the face
of the Arab world james Woolsey a former
CIA director who's one of the most
visible advocates of war told me quote
just as what we did in Germany changed
the face of Central and Eastern Europe
here we have the golden chance unquote
in this view of the salt fall the Soviet
empire really did mark what Francis
Fukuyama had called the end of history
the democratic capitalist model showed
us superiority of our other other over
social systems this model has many local
variations it brings adjustment problems
and into counters resistance such as the
anti-globalization protests in the late
1990s but it spreads through the old
Soviet territory through Latin America
and Asia and nearly everywhere except
through tragic Africa and the Islamic
Arab lands of the Middle East to think
that Arab states don't want a democratic
future is dehumanizing in this view to
think they're incapable of it is worse
whereas what is required is a first Arab
democracy and Iraq can be the place I
skipped ahead to some other analyses of
this theme then then went to to say
Richard Perle Secretary of Defense
Donald Rumsfeld and many others have
presented similar prospects at a
Pentagon briefing a few days in in
August
Rumsfeld asked rhetorically wouldn't it
be a wonderful thing if Iraq were
similar to Afghanistan meaning something
different at that time if a bad regime
were thrown out people were liberated
food would come in boarders would be
open to repression would stop prisons
would be opened I mean it would be
fabulous this transforming vision is not
to put it mildly the consensus among
those with long experience in the Middle
East quote it is so divorced from any
historical context just so far far out
of court that it is laughable
Chris Sanders a British official told me
there isn't a society just interact to
turn into a democracy that doesn't mean
you can set up institutions to put
Stooges in them but it would make about
as much sense as the South Vietnamese
experiment did others had similar
arguments Wolsey and his
might be criticized for lacking a tragic
imagination about war where war might
lead but at least they recognize that it
will lead somewhere if they are more
optimistic in their conclusions than
most of the other people I spoke with
they do see that America's involvement
in Iraq would be intimate and would be
very long it has become a cliche in
popular writing about the natural world
that small disturbances to complex
systems can have unpredictably large
effects the world of nations is perhaps
not quite as intricate as natural as the
natural world but it certainly holds the
potential for great surprise merely
itemizing the foreseeable effects of war
with Iraq suggest reverberations that
would be felt for decades if we can
judge from past Wars the effects we
can't imagine when the fighting begins
will prove to be the ones that matter
most thank you
you have three minutes to read the whole
thing you know both mark and Jim
referred to getting phone calls from
Mike Kelly the day after 9/11 and the
day of 9/11 and and I think William
langa V was also on the receiving end of
a phone call from Mike who was the
editor in chief and Cullen Murphy the
managing editor at that time and the
purpose of the call of course was to
hash out exactly how he might best
contribute to the magazine's coverage of
the tragedy and it's aftermath one
option was to fly William who was at
home in Northern California to Pakistan
from which he would make his way into
Afghanistan and join up with the
Northern Alliance as it waged war
against Al Qaeda's Taliban sponsors and
another idea was to dispatch him to New
York City to chronicle the frenetic
rescue and recovery operation that was
then already well underway amid the
ruins of the World Trade Center as soon
as the ban on air travel was lifted
William flew to New York and took a
quick reading of the disaster scene
trying to determine which municipal
efficients officials and agencies would
be entrusted with the huge job of
removing the tons of rubble and locating
the thousands of victims lying buried
deep within
at first William was stymied in his
efforts to secure access to the site
both by stonewalling officials of the
city's office of emergency management
the agency ostensibly in charge of the
operation of the rescue
recovery and by the legions of reporters
who were queuing up for press
credentials at police headquarters but
there was a piece of serendipity here
because it turned out that a man by the
name of Kenneth Holden who was the
Commissioner of a very of a relatively
small little known city agency called
the Department of design and
construction was a longtime fan of
Williams and this particular agency was
emerging as the de facto control as the
de facto supervisor of the ground zero
operations for the next nine months
William Langevin was the sole journalist
to have not only round-the-clock freedom
to interview supervisors contractors and
workers excavating the so-called pile
but also unrestricted entree to prolong
strategy sessions and seat-of-the-pants
problem-solving meet meetings among the
key players it's interesting that for
all the devastation and carnage that
William encountered day after day on the
pile he found in a surprisingly
inspiring story to tell one of
extraordinary resourcefulness and
resilience and in this excerpt that's in
the anthology which represents the sum
of the first installment of a three-part
article which at 70,000 words was the
longest piece that the Atlanta of
original reporting that the Atlantic had
ever published
William ended his writing this way
despite the epochal quote despite the
apocalyptic nature of the scene the
response was on hesitant and almost
childishly optimistic it was simply
understood that you would find survivors
and then you would find the dead and
that you would work night and day to
clean up the mess and that this would
allow the world's greatest city to
rebuild quickly
and maybe even make itself into
something better than before these are
the last words of the anthology and this
is the last piece in the book and I
think it's completely fitting that this
closed the book and I'm just a great
pleasure to have William Longo viche
here with us tonight thank you thank you
so we can relive our our glories here
yeah this some it was an odd piece but
let me talk about the Atlantic the
before doing this piece I don't know at
what point I've been working for the
Atlantic at that point for maybe 10
years or so they came at I started as a
pilot and they drifted into writing from
flying airplanes and there that for a
while the Atlantic Bill Whitworth and
Colin Murphy wanted me to write the
occasional aviation piece and I really
didn't want to write it so I did a few
aviation pieces for them but there was
this was coming up too much I didn't
want to be a an aviation writer when I
grew up so I I told Cullen you know
that's it Colin one day in Boston I'm
not writing anymore
airplane pieces that's it I quit you
know I'll write about the real things in
life and he said oh please William you
can write anything you want to write
about airplanes and I thought okay Colin
let me think there's something really
you're not gonna publish and I thought
about it for maybe 10 15 seconds I said
okay I'm gonna write about how to turn
an airplane Colin you have to publish
that and he said yes
so it's a bit of a problem for me and I
wrote the piece and was actually very
successful I mean I think for the
magazine it was successful and they
published it I mean but so that's the
kind of magazine the Atlantic is it was
a good piece yeah it turned out too so
that that's the kind of editor Colin
Murphy was and and so yeah I mean that
Atlantic Monthly now the shift seemed to
9/11 and and and this this this disaster
and the idea was was well okay go to
Pakistan and the Northern Alliance that
was the obvious thing to do back into
war or see about this this rebuilding or
clean actually cleanup effort again it's
sort of like writing about the turn I
mean of all boring things to write about
being the very idea that you would go
put a guy a journalist on the ground for
nine months and pay his expenses and
publish some long thing about garbage
which is all this was it was garbage
okay it was it was emotional garbage and
you know it was big garbage but it was
garbage it was it was like writing about
a junk pile and well they they wanted me
to do it and when the access occurred
much to our surprise then the typical by
this time it was really Mike Kelly with
all of his energy and ambition for the
magazine and it was just the green light
we don't care how long it takes we don't
care how much it cost we don't care that
we know none of us knew what was going
on what would happen but was what was
actually was going to be interesting no
idea we just knew that we had access and
so we proceeded I'll read a little bit
from it I think as far as the the the
techniques that I used in this case it's
probably natural to me in that I when I
I snuck into the site and basically and
before meeting before sending the fax to
ken hold on I don't know who this guy
was but I figured like I saw all of this
emotion and I I didn't feel very
emotional about what had happened I mean
it was a bad thing and all that but I
wasn't blown out of the water by the
fall of Twin Towers nor by the attacks
of 9/11 personally it was just war and I
saw that once I got past the soldiers
the National Guard who was they would
protect
aside from evil people like me and and I
realized that you know bless the hearts
of all the people who are digging with
shovels and their hands but it wasn't
doing you any good because the debris
was too heavy so if you're gonna find
the living and that was the attempt at
the time people thought there would be
the living trapped inside turned out not
to be true but she had to bring in heavy
equipment and so I asked who's bringing
in the heavy equipment and somebody said
this thing's all the DDC and we went
from there but the the the this sort of
sort of the source of that of that idea
of asking who's bringing the heavy
equipment I described here briefly and I
write here people who came to the site
in those early days often had the same
first sensation of leaving the city and
walking into a dream many also felt when
when they saw the extent of the
destruction that they had stumbled into
a war zone it's like something you'd see
in the movies people said probably so
but my own reaction was different when I
first went in soon after the attacks
after years of traveling through the
back corners of the world I had an
unexpected sense not of the strangeness
of this scene but of its of its
familiarity wading through the debris on
the streets climbing through the newly
torn landscapes breathing in the mixture
of smoke and dust It was as if I had
wandered wandered again into the special
havoc that failing societies tend to
visit upon themselves this time they had
visited it upon us the message seemed to
be here is a sample of our political
science I was impressed by how
faithfully the effects had been
reproduced on the ground now of course
this was not the Middle East this was
this was New York City and New York City
I mean unfortunately for the rest of the
United States is not the United States I
mean the New York City is New York City
it is the supreme the ultimate city on
earth and the what you all know of
course and so what happened there was a
he was very American but it was also
very New York and I don't
believe now looking back on it that the
reactions that I chronicled in this
series would have occurred elsewhere in
the United States we had we have today
huge evidence of the cowardice
that occurred in the rest of the country
but what I saw was not cowardice and
inside the opaque walls beyond all of
the hype about heroism was this
beautiful experiment in solving problems
in solving a very serious problem I'll
read you a little bit about that see in
other countries learn at committees
would have been formed in high
authorities consulted the ruins would
have been pondered in a tightly scripted
response would have been imposed barring
that soldiers would have assumed control
but for whatever reasons probably
cultural probably profound little of the
sort happened among those ruins where
the learned committees were excluded and
the soldiers were relegated to the
unhappy role of guarding the perimeter
and civilians and heavy machines simply
rolled in and took on the unknown nearly
everyone at the site was well paid the
money for the effort came from federal
emergency funds and it flowed freely but
despite some serious cases of corruption
and greed money was not the main
motivation here at least not until
almost the end throughout the winter and
into the springs the workers rarely
forgot the original act of aggression or
the fact that nearly 3,000 people had
died there including the friends and
relatives of some who were toiling in a
debris they were reminded of this
constantly not by the frequent discovery
of human remains in the somber visits
from grieving families but also by the
emotional response of America as a whole
and the powerful new iconic iconic
graphi iconography excuse me that was
associated with a disaster these New
York firemen as tragic heroes these
skeletal walls these smoking ruins as
America's hallowed ground whether
correctly or not the workers believe
that an important piece of history was
playing out and they wanted to
participate in it often fervently and
passed the point of fatigue from the
start that was the norm there were some
who could
stand the stress and they had to leave
but among the thousands who stayed
almost all sought greater involvement
rather than less the truth is the people
relished the experience it's obvious
that they would never have wished this
calamity on themselves or others but
inside the perimeter lines and beyond
the public's view it served for many of
them as an unexpected liberation a
national tragedy of course but one that
was contained unambiguous and
surprisingly energizing was this not war
after all
probably it was though at some early an
entirely willing stage of the fighting
people believed wholeheartedly that they
were righting a wrong and it was their
duty to act quickly the urgency of the
job swept away ordinary responsibilities
and the everyday dullness of family life
and it made nonsense of office paperwork
and tedious professional routines
traditional hierarchies broke down to
the problems that had to be solved were
largely unprecedented action and
invention were required on every level
often with no need or possibility of
asking permission as a result within the
vital new culture that grew up at the
Trade Center site even the lowliest
laborers and firemen were given power
many of them rose to it and some of them
sank among those who gained the greatest
influence were people without previous
rank who discovered balance and ability
within themselves and who in turn were
discovered by others the unexpected ones
were front-line firemen and construction
workers young engineers and obscure city
employees their success in the midst of
chaos was an odd twist in the story of
these monolithic buildings that in the
final stretch of the 20th century had
stood so visibly for the totalitarian
ideals of planning and control but the
buildings were not buildings anymore and
the place where they fell had become
tabula rasa for the United States among
the ruins now a large and unscripted
experiment in American life had gotten
away I'll say one more thing about it
just on a personal note I was very
consumed by what was going on there I
was working seven days a week I my job
was to try to make something of this
for my beloved editors and readers and
it was a constant concern so I had no
time to read the newspaper I had no time
to do anything other than to be at the
site and deal with the work that I was
doing no time so I was quite unaware of
what was happening elsewhere in the
United States at the same time I mean I
knew about the the the idiocy of
shutting down the Airlines for three
days I knew a few basics like that but I
was not aware of the level of reaction
and pathology that was rising in the
rest of the country outside of the sight
I had an unduly optimistic view of the
reaction to 9/11 because I was at the
World Trade Center site I regret that
today I regret that I did not put it
wasn't my assignment it wasn't my
mandate but I think the piece would have
been better had I mentioned in a few
words acknowledged in a few words that
elsewhere in the country things were not
going so well having said that let me
recommend what seems to me perhaps to be
the best piece in this beautiful
anthology and if you're buying the book
well you'll find it by George Kennan I
just would like I'm not gonna speak
about it it was written in the 1950s in
reaction to the McCarthy hysteria and
the title is the illusion of security it
is a book it is a piece which applies
today to our problems who we are what we
have become what we are doing in Iraq
what we are doing to our civil liberties
what we have done the damage that
probably cannot be undone where is
George Kennan read this piece it's also
a beautiful piece of writing thank you
thank you very much this has been such a
celebration of writing it's very moving
to see how much the this kind of writing
can illuminate our world and teach us
things that we didn't know and that we
need to know and whether it's fiction or
nonfiction so thank you all for coming
thanks for coming down it was very good
of you and the authors will be here to
sign the American idea the best of the
Atlantic Monthly is edited by Robert
Baer for more visit the Atlantic com